prima pensa poi parla siamo tutti
cresciuti con questa regola aurea prima
di parlare dobbiamo pensare ed è anche
abbastanza logico non pensate se sei un
interprete però questa regola non vale
più
noi interpreti pensiamo e parliamo nello
stesso momento e non solo
ascoltiamo pensiamo traduciamo e
parliamo nello stesso momento
ma come fate e come ci riuscite
questa è una domanda ricorrente che mi
fanno sempre
ve lo spiego così siamo un po i dj della
parola avete mai fatto caso un dj tutto
intento in consolle chino di lato con un
orecchio coperto dalla cuffia e l'altro
libero il dj ascolta in cuffia la
canzone che sta per lanciare e
dell'orecchio libero tiene sotto
controllo la musica in sala in questo
modo riesce a rendere pulito il
passaggio da una canzone e l'altra e noi
siamo felicissimi e poi abbiamo
spensierati l'interprete fa lo stesso
con le parole durante un convegno
l'oratore inizia il suo discorso e il
pubblico ascolta comodamente la
traduzione attraverso le cuffie
nel frattempo però dovete sapere che
accade qualcosa nelle retrovie della
cabina la voce dell'oratore proprio come
la musica per il dj arriva dalle cuffie
al nostro orecchio e viene trasmessa al
cervello che si attiva molto rapidamente
per comprendere elaborare e tradurre il
discorso che viene trasmesso poi al
microfono e ai nostri ascoltatori i
nostri ascoltatori quindi proprio come
noi che parliamo spensieratamente al
ritmo della musica del dj si godono
tranquilli il nostro discorso a prima
vista questo processo può sembrare
naturale e semplice ma non lo è di
recente
ho guardato con interesse un
documentario che descriveva la
meravigliosa tecnica di caccia delle
tigri del bengala
ma voi lo sapete perché il loro manto e
arancione e nero
ebbene perché il sistema visivo delle
loro prede non è in grado di percepire
l'arancione che appare quindi verde ai
loro occhi
in questo modo la tigre si mimetizza
perfettamente e può agire nell'ombra
ecco penso che noi interpreti siamo un
po come le tigri del bengala
il nostro obiettivo è che le nostre
parole siano talmente ben mimetizzate
nel contesto culturale di chi ci ascolta
che ciò che ascolta deve sembrare
pronunciato direttamente nella sua
lingua
il nostro lavoro non consiste solamente
nell'ascoltare una lingua e nel ripetere
qualche concetto in un'altra
l'attività cerebrale in corso è molto
complessa e particolarmente e stancante
proprio per questo motivo noi simultanee
sti come una coppia di anziani signori
che giocano a briscola affiatati
compagni da anni comuni con a notti
senza parlare fanno gioco di squadra per
vincere anche noi viaggiano sempre in
coppia
se il nostro incarico si potrai per
lungo tempo in questo modo possiamo
darci il cambio di mezz'ora in mezz'ora
riposarci riprendere fiato sostenerci a
vicenda
talvolta proprio ricorrendo ai motti
alcune teorie ritengono che lo sforzo
mentale degli interpreti si è
equiparabile a quello degli astronauti
sullo spazio l'attività neuronale e la
modalità di funzionamento delle regioni
del nostro cervello sono oggetto di
studi che riguardano tra le altre cose
la psicolinguistica e gli aspetti
neurocognitivi il cervello
dell'interprete deve essere allenato
flessibile rapido e ricettivo un
individuo che ascolta traduce e parla
nello stesso momento induce il proprio
sistema cerebrale a mettere in campo un
sistema di interconnessione funzionali
molto potenti che avviene in varie
regioni del cervello
questa costante e complessa attività
cerebrale consuma una grande quantità di
energie
avete presente chi sono i cuoca e cuoca
sono quei simpatici e voraci marsupiali
australiani che mangiano volentieri e
direi di continuo il cibo loro offerto
vi do un consiglio spassionato non
lasciate mai caffè è che incustoditi
durante un convegno perché potrebbero
esserci degli interpreti na4 ma battute
a parte proprio come questi allegri
marsupiali noi ci nutriamo di continuo e
assumiamo tanta tanta caffeina perché la
nostra attenzione deve essere sempre
vigile e costante allerta
mi ricorda sempre un po la nostra amica
tigre di qualche secondo fa
dobbiamo essere sempre vigili per poter
identificare possibili insidie e
comprendere al meglio il messaggio che
devono trasmettere all aiuto nostri
utenti del servizio
dobbiamo avere pieno controllo della
situazione del tema trattato e delle
lingue che utilizziamo in entrata e in
uscita si potrebbe pensare che subentri
una buona dose di angoscia o per lo meno
è quello che pensano le persone che ci
osservano dall'esterno ho anche un po
incuriosite in verità vi dirò quando ci
sediamo in cabina e indossiamo le nostre
cuffie ci sentiamo come un surfista che
a bordo della sua bella tavola scruta
l'orizzonte in attesa delle onde in
arrivo quando vede l'onda perfetta la
sua honda si volta iniziare mare con
vigore perché non c'è margine di errore
in questa situazione o prende l'onda o
rischia di essere centrifugato sotto la
sua forza prorompente questo si chiama
adrenalina quindi prima di prendere
l'onda noi ci sentiamo emozionati pn
riina lina nei confronti degli yacht ma
quando accendiamo il nostro microfono
tutto scompare siamo sulla cresta
dell'onda e ci godiamo lo spettacolo
come descrivereste ora un interprete
io direi di sicuro che siamo tutti
d'accordo sul multi tasche
questo mi fa pensare al polpo il polpo
lo conosciamo tutti è una misteriosa
creatura marina con delle
caratteristiche speciali questi
cefalopodi sono molto ordinati ed
estremamente intelligenti i loro
tentacoli a momenti autonome infatti due
terzi e dico due terzi dei loro neuroni
risiedono proprio nei tentacoli è
perfettamente normale pertanto per loro
ricorrere a un tentacolo per risolvere
un compito come aprire una conchiglia
mentre con l'altro tentacolo si possono
dedicare tranquillamente ad altro
gli interpreti fanno esattamente la
stessa cosa non si limitano a tradurre
simultaneamente parola per parola devono
focalizzarsi anche sulla qualità della
voce e dei concetti che entrano nei loro
microfoni ascoltare capire tradurre
parlare e allo stesso tempo cercare i
concetti online chiedere supporto alla
collega tutto simultaneamente
direi quindi che facciamo davvero
concorrenza al polpo e i suoi
intelligenti tentacoli multifunzione
ecco quindi che la prossima volta che
ascoltate o vedete un interprete
ricordate che avete davanti agli occhi
una figura una creatura speciale che in
un unico corpo e non unicamente
racchiude le caratteristiche di dj volpi
tigri bocca astronauti e naturalmente
abili giocatori di briscola
venite a gustarmi in cabina al prossimo
convegno grazie
[Musica]